this is devante chisholm reading for
jordan remay and gabe gerwin assassin's
creed valhalla's main story may take
around 60 hours to complete but that
doesn't mean avora's adventures are done
just yet dawn of ragnarok the game's
newest dlc is a 35-hour adventure that
sees avor stepping into the shoes of
odin once more and changes the
assassin's creed formula in fun new ways
here's everything you need to know about
assassin's creed valhalla dawn of
ragnarok
in ac valhalla the asgard and jodenheim
sagas conclude with javi aka odin
learning that there's no way for them to
physically survive ragnarok however they
can undergo an experimental procedure to
be born again that's where assassin's
creed sages come from we come to
discover the sages are actually isu from
javi's time that go on to be reborn as
humans knowing that they and their
allies will be reborn following ragnarok
javi faces the coming end of the world
and donna ragnarok picks up there with
hobbies seeking out their son balder who
has been kidnapped and imprisoned within
the realm of dwarves a land that has
been consumed by war ahead of ragnarok
javi's quest will see them once again
face the frost giants of jodenheim but
this time they'll go up against a more
fiery foe sirder though the expansion
takes place after the events of asgard
and jodenheim sagas you'll be able to
jump into donna ragnarok even if you
haven't completed those storylines the
developer ubisoft sophia told gamespot
that it has taken special care to make
sure that new players will be just as
engaged with the narrative as those that
have completed valhalla adding to this
when we asked the ubisoft montreal why
donna ragnarok was made dlc instead of a
standalone title it responded quote the
team has made efforts to make all
content be more accessible to players
expansions included so they can explore
the world of valhalla not unlike a theme
park we wanted players to be able to
choose which saga they embark on be it
england ireland frankia and now the
realm of dwarves expansions one and two
focused more on the viking facet of
valhalla and explored avor as a
character under different circumstances
now dawn of ragnarok feels like the
other side of the coin where we go
deeper into the north mythology and more
so into odin slash hobby's backstory the
studio went on to say quote given how
important north mythology was to the
vikings everyday life we felt donna
ragnarok needed to be included in
assassin's creed valhalla
in this game you'll be exploring the
mythical dwarven realm of sfarthelheim a
region that's only accessible via volca
raventhorpe's seer in a similar manner
to asgard and jodenheim in the game's
main campaign this land historically
said to be ruled by dwarves has seen the
native community scattered into hiding
spots to avoid destruction and forced
labor ubisoft's sophia has avoided the
common trope of having buff bearded
dudes with scottish accents for this
role instead depicting the dwarves as a
slightly smaller human-like race the dev
also noted that ragnarok's map is
one-third the size of valhalla's england
[Music]
in dawn of ragnarok odin has a number of
special abilities that weren't available
during valhalla's other mythical
excursions acquirable through a new
skill tree these abilities include the
power of the raven which lets odin
temporarily turn into a bird to quickly
scale mountains or get the drop on
enemies as well as the appearance
changing power of muskelheim
another one of these abilities is power
of rebirth a skill that when activated
temporarily turns anyone odin kills into
an ally use it at an opportune time such
as when you're facing an enormous number
of enemies and you can change the fight
from being a lost cause into an all-out
slaughter in your favor
you do have to choose carefully though
however as only a few of these abilities
can be equipped at a time their use is
also tied to a new resource hooger which
you can get from enemies certain objects
in the environment and shrines though
the latter option requires a sacrifice
of health in order to do so
it always provides
this give and take balancing of these
powers looks like it will be most
interesting in dawn of ragnarok's combat
arenas these gauntlets provide extra
challenges in exchange for ever
increasing rewards tied to their
difficulty ubisoft sophia told gamespot
quote we wanted to really make a
difference in all players gameplay no
matter if they like face-to-face combat
stealthily taking out the opposition
exploring the realm of dwarves in search
of the dwarves ancient secrets and
mystery or solving puzzles to get the
valuable treasure the powers let odin
reach inaccessible locations give them
new stealth opportunities let them
traverse the world in a different manner
and lay devastation on the forces of
jodenheim and muspelheim alongside the
mythical abilities odin also has an
entirely new weapon type in dawn of
ragnarok the atgire based on the
viking's own spear but resembling
something out of monster hunter it's a
powerful two-handed weapon with its own
combo system it's also capable of
delivering powerful blows into the
ground as well as swift attacks to take
out several enemies
did my tale please you valkyrie donna
ragnarok is coming from ubisoft sophia
the lead studio for assassin's creed iii
liberation assassin's creed rogue and
assassin's creed origins the curse of
the prophets dlc guiles armstrong is
senior scriptwriter for donna ragnarok
and his work includes being lead writer
on destruction all-stars and a writer
for marvel's guardians of the galaxy
assassin's creed valhalla dawn of
ragnarok releases on ps4 ps5 xbox one
xbox series x and s stadia and pc on
march 10. and even though it's the size
of a full game this is still considered
dlc and will only cost you 40 bucks 15
more than wrath of the druids and the
siege of paris and there you have it
everything you need to know about
assassin's creed valhalla dawn of
ragnarok
if you're excited to play this massive
expansion make sure to let us know in
the comments below we'll have more
videos about the game once it launches
including our review so make sure you
subscribe so you get notified when it
becomes available
gentlemen
[Music]
[Music]
you